Gregg is gonna start us off this hour in
Tennessee
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Gregg
thank you sir thanks for taking my call
sure what's up my question is I have
been you know a list of yours for
decades and never took my naps of peace
but I fall of it pretty much your rules
999 times out of a hundred my question
is for those of us who have become
debt-free and we have no debt and at
what point in time do we realize hey
I've busted my butt say for decades when
do I determine when can I start
splurging some with my finances you know
by little not really know like a toy or
a car or whatever yeah probably about
five years ago for you you're probably
late what happens to us is what happens
to us is that we live like no one else
so that later we can live and give like
no one else and then we forget to do it
okay so you've lived like no one else
you've you know you've been on rice and
beans and you got out of debt and you
got used to living on the cheap and
you've been piling up money and you've
done a great job and you're probably
debt free probably got a big pile of
money and you know and now it's
emotionally hard to loosen up a little
bit because you're afraid exactly you're
afraid you're gonna screw it up exactly
so the rule I use is is that when I'm
working with people who have built some
wealth and struggling with that and
sometimes honestly Sharon and I struggle
with it
because our money has grown more than
our emotional grasp of it we feel it we
still feel like we are worth a lot less
than we're actually mathematically worth
you know what I'm saying correct yeah
and so we have to what we say is if
we're gonna splurge if we're gonna buy
something that's just a crazy what we
used to would call a crazy luxury item
like when we were broke people and we
would say no one should ever spend that
on that have you ever heard that you
know and so yeah and you're getting
ready to now you're getting ready to
spend that on that which is very cool
you should
by that car you know so the rule of
thumb I use is this what is the ratio of
that to my net worth
okay so let's pretend
let's use an example let's pretend you
had a million dollars in mutual funds in
your 401k how much have you got just in
401k or all total all total about 1.7
million okay cool I was guessing
outright okay
so way to go congratulations you did it
okay so let's say you bought a crazy but
$100,000 car okay okay and you didn't
even put insurance on it and you forgot
to set the brake and it went off the
cliff and burned
now you're worth 1.6 million well
whoop-dee-do pee now that's the kind of
a bizarre example but I mean if you just
completely set $100,000 on fire in your
backyard
and watched it burn you winner that
wouldn't change your life at all okay so
you can splurge like that and it you
know but now if you start talking about
you're gonna spend 800 grand on
something crazy that's half your
freaking world we got to stop and think
about this one right you see what I'm
doing now I've got a friend that's
working I got a friend that's worth 200
million Wow
so him buying a $200,000 car is like
most people buying a biscuit mm-hmm
right ratio wise it doesn't matter it
doesn't affect his life and yet you know
where I grew up in the way I grew up no
one should ever spend that on a car well
he makes he's got hundreds of millions
of dollars it's irrelevant he gives more
than that in charity in 20 minutes the
ministries he supports with zero zero
zeros on the end and he has a nice car
and people gripe at him about his car of
course you know but the guy's got you
know it's a small percentage of his
world so the way you know you're not
screwing up is if you set fire to that
much money would it screw up your life
okay and so if you want to go on
and you've always wanted to take a
cruise around the world it's $28,000 or
it's or it's a hundred and twenty eight
thousand dollars you can do it and enjoy
that vacation and it really will not
affect your life you've earned the right
mathematically if you want to give that
much to somebody do you find the charity
you a ministry and God says for you to
you know let's let's build this thing a
small house over here for 100 grand or
something you can do that and it will
not affect your life but that's how
that's how we gauge it is if after this
thing if it just was set fire to are we
still okay are we still did we even
notice and if the answer is no then
we're not spending too much on that and
so okay does that make sense yeah but
you don't really have like a percentage
that you know I would just say you know
I mean it's kind of a common-sense thing
though if it's approaching fifty percent
it would be too much right this proves
to me how cheap I am I'm just looking at
splurge and maybe spending fifteen grand
yeah you're too cheap you need to go buy
that today this is why you did all this
you've worked your butt off man you came
from nothing and you have 1.7 million am
i right correct no one gave you this
money you didn't hit the lottery you've
been working your butt off and being
diligent you've earned the right to
enjoy your money I used to work 60 hours
a week yep I know you you don't get to
have 1.7 million working 30 hours a week
you know correct
you're an every day millionaire you fit
the typology exactly and all I'm doing
is saying yes you you you not only have
permission you almost have the emotional
obligation to treat yourself to some
things and you need to make sure you're
doing some generosity things that match
that to be there and I get more joy out
of that than I do being the selfish
person buying it for my personal cell
absolutely so that's another thing we do
is if we spend $15,000 on item we might
go buy 3 used cars for single moms and
spend 15,000 on them sometimes we match
ourselves
and maybe that's just because we're you
know so we don't feel guilty or
something but maybe it's also just
keeping us in balance because if you got
generosity of spending running about the
same level and neither one of them are
draining you down to where you're broke
you're living a good life okay thank you
very much for your hey I appreciate
getting to talk to you thank you for
letting me get up on my soapbox because
here that's something wonderful because
I don't get to take that call very often
most of times you guys are on the other
side you're trying to learn to be that
guy you want to be him when you grow up
but live like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
no discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
scripture says the diligent prosper
scripture says not the lazy not the ones
who run their mouth the diligent dream
what do you say 60 hours a week I heard
it great place to go when you're broke
to work